most of you won't be successful not
because you can't do it but you can't
outlash Oh oh you long enough to get to
your noodle everything great in your
life is on the other side of your
greatest fears it makes sense to get up
and start your day early because you can
get more work out
rise and shine it's ain't spresso time
what's up believe nation it's evan i
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message fight over to you
eric thomas also if you want to know at
eric and other successful entrepreneurs
have to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days i will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below even if you've my
closest friend i have boundaries when
i've been telling you to get that gold
get that drink and i'm just been telling
you driving and driving and driving and
driving what i've been talking about is
consistency freshman year in college me
and my boys start like this like
christian like organizations
[Music]
I know many you saw this game they were
down by 20 they were down by 20 that's
pretty much down by 20 and Golden State
No down by 20 away so boom multiple
businesses right so but before this
happened if anybody has been studying
him closely
what happened before this game happened
77 three-pointers in a row this boy made
77 three-point shots in practice they
were down about 20 points he came back
and won the game but you might have
missed it take him to the slide see do
you see it he's shooting a three-pointer
with his eyes closed they show that on
SportsCenter the boy's eyes is closed
with the three boom muscle memory his
eyes is closed what was he thinking
about he was thinking about in practice
one in practice 277 and he started
saying to himself we down by three
points three times seven is twenty-one
let me give him the business one defense
- defense guys don't worry about it just
give me the rock you sure remember what
I did in practice seconds left he not
even at home he away from home he got
his eyes closed with one of the best
defenders checking them
you've been lazy your whole life and now
somebody told you you could make six
figures and you go knock on the door 100
times and your body say you a lot you
ain't never gave 100% and/or they're not
gonna do a hundred times you're gonna
have to get 120 you get up out of here
you can't do this and you won't have to
fight and fight and fight and fight and
most of you won't be successful not
because you can't do it but you can't
outlash oh oh you
enough to get to your new room I'm
leaving I'm gonna say it again
you can't get past oh oh you two get to
your new you every time you dedicate
yourself just my year I'm gonna make it
happen you don't make it happen this kid
didn't take his team to the most wins
this year because of what he does in the
game
I'm accounting for you one defense
somebody tell me I'm sorry Davis how
tall this Davis 1672 wingspan he right
there
I see somebody else looked like a small
for a small forward inside there right
there I got another guy coming around
right there he got his eyes closed and
he shoots over this is your year this is
your year
this is your year this is your moment
you saw your boy et do it this is your
year this is your moment if not you who
have not not win this is you baby ain't
nobody stopping you but you ain't nobody
stop you but you do not a ver adopt
acting like you're not average while you
be average you not a verage why are you
being good when you're not good you
grades you phenomenal when you gonna
step up to the plate you will let a high
school dropout somebody lived in banded
buildings somebody ate out of trash how
do you I couldn't hardly read when I got
to college you gonna let me out do you
crazier than that you don't fight to be
the new you because you don't believe
that you could be that person you'd love
for it to happen you'd love for those
things up on your vision board to come
true but because you don't think you're
capable of doing it you don't put in the
effort
why put in all that work if it's not
gonna happen the truth is there is a
small piece of you that believes you can
do it but it's being suffocated by your
fear I look at my own case as an example
I'm about to go off and do something
that's very scary for me I'm doing a 90
day tour of the United States we're
hitting up 23 different cities in 90
days and when I first did it the tour
alone is not scary for me when I first
announced it my idea was
I would go and do free coffee shop
meetups that's low risk that's not scary
because if nobody shows up nobody shows
up it's great no problem if one person
shows up awesome I'll have a great
one-on-one conversation if 50 people
show up then great we've just packed the
room there's no risk there's no fear
it's not scary and I went to New York
and my agent called me out on it he said
Evan you're thinking small Evan you're
playing a small game because you're
afraid of going off and taking a bigger
shot because you're afraid that people
are not gonna show up if you did a paid
event and it was right and so now I have
to do it now I have to do paid events I
have to do it to eat the beer and listen
maybe still nobody shows up maybe only
one person shows up maybe zero maybe we
booked the room we booked a venue in
each of these 23 cities and then nobody
shows up or one person shows up one is
probably worse than nobody at least with
with one at least with zero I get to
walk away but with one person I have to
still go on and do my show that's
terrifying that's terrifying for me and
then I have to repeat that nightmare
every four days you have one city for
days another city for tea another city
for days another city for 90 days it's
gonna be crazy but because I'm afraid of
it I have to go off and do it and
because I love over-delivering
value it's I'm gonna bring the best of
me to each of those cities it's gonna be
a life-changing experience for the
people who come to the workshops whether
one person shows up or 100 I'm gonna
bring my best is gonna be amazing but
I'm afraid to do it and so I have to do
it and the younger version of Evan
probably would have found a logical
reason why not to do it well I can't do
it because I'm too busy I can't do it
because I don't want to put in the work
to book all the speaking gigs I can't do
it because blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah right the logic there's lots of
logical reasons why I shouldn't do it
and you're tricking yourself with your
logic your brain is getting in your way
we're really underneath the reasons is
you're just afraid you're just afraid
and that's okay
it's okay to be afraid it's normal to be
afraid if you're doing something new
different big that's outside what most
people are doing in your circle you're
going to be afraid
that's okay it's okay but call it what
it is don't come up with some logical
reasons why you shouldn't do something
just say I'm afraid and when you're
feeling that fear it's not be fearless
it's feel the fear and do it anyway
everything great in your life is on the
other side of that fear everything great
in your life is on the other side of
your greatest fears so let's step into
it together and see what magic we can
create so how do you do it how do you
step into the fear I'm gonna give you
three ways to do it
way number one is having an environment
for excellence you are a product of your
environment and yes you are born into an
environment but now you get to create
you get to build your own environment
and it starts with what's on your walls
like where are you working what's the
physical environment you're in these
people all mean something around
believed to me these people I set this
up once and I get inspired every time I
walk into my office so it starts with
your physical environment and then goes
to the clothes you wear expression right
like why am i wearing this ET shirt or
wearing wearing my belief shirts I feel
like I'm Batman now I'm a superhero
going to work off an important mission
how are you expressing yourself it goes
to the videos that you're watching
what's your daily habit do you turn on
one of my videos and get believe in the
morning do you turn on one of et's
videos and get more courageous in the
morning like what are you doing on a
daily it's not about doing one thing
that you feel courageous about and then
you fall back down to normal it's the
daily it's what you are feeding your
head with it's what you're looking at on
a every single day basis that starts to
shift you every single day ever so
slightly it shifts you it makes you more
bold and makes you more confident makes
you more courageous it makes you more
willing to step into your fear if you
are around people even if it's just in a
video format if you're around people
you're watching videos of people who are
doing courageous things of people who
are tackling their fears I guarantee you
if you do that every day I guarantee you
you will be more willing on a daily to
take small little courageous steps
forward and face your fears too so set
up your environment have an environment
of excellence way number two is soar
with Mentors the more you have somebody
actually in your face in your life who
is pushing you forward it's gonna help
you move right my agent was the guy who
said Evan you're thinking small I went
to the coffee shop in New York I did a
meet-up event I
50 people or so come out we packed the
place it was amazing so he said I left
there feeling amazing like this is great
holy cat look all these people showed up
what an amazing evening with all these
entrepreneurs and and then I go to have
dinner with my agent and he kicks my ass
you know he says this sucks like you're
you're thinking small you're just afraid
you should be doing something bigger and
so having people around you in your life
who are mentors for you who allow you to
soar soar with your mentors is really
important and the key to getting the
mentor is not to go up to somebody and
say hey will you be my mentor it's after
one piece of advice ask for one piece of
advice and then go and do that work my
agent gave me a piece of advice you
should be doing this as a paid tour I
don't want to do a paid towards scary
and crazy okay
that's the advice I'm gonna do it don't
go to a mentor ask for advice not take
the answer and then go ask another
question that's the ultimate disrespect
to the Mentors and so it's why people
mostly don't have mentors because you're
asking wrong you're going in asking will
you be my mentor which they don't want
to jump into that relationship until you
ask for help on a question they give me
advice and you don't do the work on that
thing they don't want to help you
anymore mentors the good ones give you
difficult tasks that's their job that's
their role their role is to push you
forward to where you need to be and so
when they give you something you go off
and do it soar with mentors and we
number three is commit immediately
commit immediately as soon as you get an
idea as soon as you say I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do my paint tour I'm
gonna do that scary thing I'm gonna make
a youtube video I'm going to whatever
the case is for your life as soon as you
commit to it immediate action as soon as
you say I'm gonna do this book it right
away for me as soon as I said I'm gonna
book my tour great I went home and I
started emailing people on my team
here's what we're doing guys and you're
committing especially if you commit to
somebody else the immediate action isn't
I'm gonna go and start researching
venues that's okay but it's easy to wake
up the next day and that motivation is
gone and then all you see is the fear in
front of you again and so when you
commit to other people you're way more
likely to follow through and actually do
the thing so as soon as you get that
idea
soon as you've recognized that it's not
just logic talking but it's deep down
actually your fear talking to you and
you know the thing that you have to do
is walk right into that fear look us
straight in the face and keep marching
forward as soon as you've made that
commitment then take immediate action
and commit to somebody else and say here
is my plan don't wait til tomorrow
don't wait till next week don't wait
till January first arbitrary day don't
wait then now immediately action commit
to somebody else so have an environment
of excellence soar with mentors and
commit immediately so that you can push
through that fear and recognize your
greatness on the other side now I've got
a really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for question of the day I want to
know what do you want to fight for let
me know put in the comments below
I've been with you for a long way at the
one moment that stands out out of we've
done I don't know how many done we've
done know what eight hundred events the
one time was 4:00 a.m. we went out to
practice at 4:00 a.m. and that was your
idea to do it well then you know all
these Nike people are like no no no no
let's not let's not do that and then
you're like let's do it at 4:00 a.m. so
you got security
you got brand marketing sports marketing
going no no no no no no that's not good
you're like let's do it because that's
your sustenance right I mean to me it
just makes complete sense not to us see
we all right what you usually I'm
sleeping at 4 a.m. you're here working
out so talk about that ok so if if your
job is to try to be the best basketball
player you can be alright to do that you
have to practice you have to train right
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can so if you get up at
10:00 in the morning
train at 11:00 12:00 say 12:00 train at
12:00 train for two hours 12:00 to 2:00
you have to let your body recover so you
eat recover whatever you get back out
you train start training again at 6:00
train from 6:00 to 8:00 right and now
you go home shower you eat dinner you go
to bed you wake up do it again right
those are two sessions all right now
imagine you wake up at 3:00 you train at
4:00 you go 4 to 6 come home breakfast
relax so so now you're back at it again
9:00 to 11:00 right relax and now it's
done you're back at it again to the four
and have you're back at it again you
know 7 to 9
look how much more training I have done
by simply starting at 4:00 all right so
now you do that and as the years go on
the separation that you have with your
competitors and your peers just grows
larger and larger and larger and larger
and larger and by year five or six
doesn't matter what kind of work they're
doing a summer they're never going to
catch up because they're five years
behind so it makes sense to get up and
start your day early because you can get
more work is that genetic or is that
something you you engrained and trained
yourself no it was not you that for me
it was it was just common sense like I
can I can if I start earlier I can train
more hours and I know the other guys
aren't doing it because I know
what their training schedule is so I
know if I do this consistently over time
is that the gaps just gonna widen and
why no why no why no why and they won't
be able to get that back how do you
develop that or where do you what do you
learn that from well I I think it's just
no it's just a matter of what's
important to you mhm
what's important to you for whatever
reason you know I felt like I didn't
feel good about myself if I wasn't doing
everything I could to be the best
version of myself if I felt like I left
anything on a table it would eat away at
me I wouldn't be able to look myself in
the mirror right so the reason why I can
retire now and be completely comfortable
about it because I know that I've done
everything I could to be the best
basketball player I could be if you want
to learn how to activate your beast mode
like Eric Thomas check out a video link
right next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the DNA of your success is in your
routine you're not as deep as you think
you are
you've got a final week a I'm getting up
at 3:00 and stick with it I'm getting up
at 5:00 and stick with it